So, this is probably what you think of when you
picture an atom, right?
The thing is, the central part of this model
is just plain inaccurate.
Scientists recently found the nucleus of some
atoms don’t look like this at all, and it’s
causing a ruckus because well, this newfound
shape straight up shouldn’t exist.
When you learned about atoms in school, you
probably learned about a couple of different
models-- and one thing was likely always the
same- the nucleus was spherical.
But it turns out that might’ve been too
simple.
Atomic nuclei are made up of protons and neutrons
that are held together by the Strong Nuclear
Force (one of the universe’s fundamental
forces), and based on this, one might assume
they’d be more or less spherical.
In reality, though, most nuclei are deformed
to some extent, they can be elongated into
football shapes or squished into discs-- but
as long as they’re symmetrical everything
in physics land is fine and dandy.
Here’s the problem though, we just found
a nucleus that ISN’T symmetrical, and it’s
a huge deal.
And that’s because symmetry is a very important
cornerstone to many of the theories we use
to understand the universe.
In particle physics, there’s a theory called
CP-Symmetry, which is the combination of charge
symmetry and parity.
Charge symmetry is the idea that if you flip
the charge of an atom, the physics of the
atom shouldn’t change.
This is the basis to our understanding of
antimatter- if you flip the charge in a regular
atom, you get an anti-atom.
The physics should work the same.
Similarly, Parity is the idea that if you
invert the spatial coordinates of a system,
the physics shouldn’t change.
Our hands, for example, show parity- if you
move one hand like this, you can mirror it
with your other hand- and it works the same
way.
Theoretically, atoms should behave this way,
too.
So, back to the new hotness.
Some Scotland-based scientists confirmed a
pear-shaped nucleus exists.
A PEAR, YOU GUYS!
The most exciting shape of all the fruits!!!
Scientists had previously found asymmetrical
nuclei in the isotopes Radium-224 and 226,
But this time they confirmed it in Barium-144,
which is a comparatively lighter atom.
And how’d they do it you ask?
They just looked for octupole transitions
in the gamma ray emissions of excited ba-144
nuclei, casual.
And the surprisingly pear-shaped nuclei they
found had uneven distributions of mass, and
charge.
Which according to currently accepted models
of physics, like CP-symmetry, just shouldn’t
exist.
But THEY DO.
And the scientists think that could have some
very big implications.
Our current models predict the symmetry of
antimatter and matter, and of the flow of
time, but the scientists think that these
nuclei being asymmetrical could explain why
these other things don’t function symmetrically
either.
If some atomic nuclei aren’t symmetrical…
they’re claiming it could explain why we
can’t seem to find antimatter in our universe,
and why time always flows from past to future
-- and therefore, why time travel is likely
impossible :(
These are some pretty hefty claims, though,
and as always more research is needed before
we can prove anything.
But it is pretty amazing that such a tiny
discovery could have such huge implications,
innit?
Special thanks to Domain dot com for sponsoring
this episode of Seeker!
Domain dot com is awesome, affordable, reliable,
and has all the tools you need to build a
new website.
Start sharing your ideas with the world on
a professional website.
Domain can fulfill all your professional needs,
they offer .com and .net domain names and
intuitive website builders, they have over
three hundred domain extensions to fit your
needs, from dot club to dot space, to dot
family to dot pizza!
Take that first step in creating an identity
online and visit domain dot com.
If tiny science gets you as excited as a barium-144
nucleus, you should watch Julian’s video
about just how small life can get, here.
And fun fact, about 99.9% percent of an atom
is empty space - without it, all of humanity
would be the size of a sugar cube.
Don’t forget to subscribe and thanks for
watching Seeker!